how does one come to know the C's dark  secrets monsters are they real  I want you to tell me what happened tell  me the secret of the Essex I don't  expect a writer to understand mr. novel  promised me to come back I'll come back  as quick as his thumbs nice lair  normally a captain gets to choose this  first man an experienced captain yes  centuries before sailors feared sailing  off the edge of the earth  but we were headed for the edge of  sanity  I believe you have seen things no one  else has seen what is it  we can roll away  Charlie Parrish out there  those who could I be who are going home  I live in three he's mine  so it's true yes  too much is true  you  you